[Musique]
m
inviter les spectateurs bonjour bonjour
et non pas très joli à une volée d'une
crème anglaise quelle drôle d'idée dit
pas d'où ça vient
c'est vraiment anglais la crème nos
collègues anglophones ou allophones
ces deux réseaux globaux
d'abord parce que la grande demoiselle
n'a pas voulu opposer le roi
d'angleterre parce qu'ils ne mangeaient
pas d'ortolans c'est une chose
importante ensuite parce que le roi
d'angleterre est mort parce qu'il avait
mangé trop de l'endroit royan premier
alors la lamproie et les ortolans étant
une des spécialités de son pays au
moment où la bouche glossy c'est
l'instinct est né voulait clair voir
pourquoi ces 16es crème anglaise
les appels de la crème anglaise n'est
pas mon fort c'est une les anciens et
très ancien les aspire à la nuit les
temps appellent ça qu'un bon allemand en
tout cas depuis la guerre de cent ans
dans peut-être les allergènes notre ami
robert keating qui a à ses côtés madame
jacqueline girard et qui va peut-être
via jakin gérard vous êtes l'auteur d'un
petit livre qui s'appelle mille et une
recettes au cassé yab je n'aurais jamais
pensé qu' à étendre cette base de café
mais je crois bien que je les ai
sélectionné retrouve amy levin faut
quand même préciser qu'il n'y en a pas
mille et une dans la limousine façon de
parler
fa c'est du bluff alors je crois qu'on
pourra trouver mieux bon en tout cas le
cas c'est évidemment tout le monde le
connaît on en boîte à corte content de
sa voix qui avait 1000 recettes ou café
mille et une recettes qui préférait le
boire plutôt de le manger
bien sûr il ya même une très jolie les
chandelles et la légende du début du
cash et je crois que c'est un berger
arabe raconte que c'est un chevrier
chevrier est que ces chèvres
s'éparpiller dans la nature et quand
elle revit n'est
batifolait j'étais énervé c'est ça il ya
les mêmes à vieux boucau qui avait
repris de la vigueur en mangeant des
graines de cadencer pas quoi qu'il en
soit dans ses recettes
il y en a une qui est une crème anglaise
au café salaire tout simple et je crois
que c'est très difficile a réussi enfin
pas pour vous bien sûr parce que tout
est une spécialiste mais je crois que
c'est assez difficile a aussi je crois
que c'est celle là qui aurait motivé a
choisi pour la paix et pour la montrer
aux téléspectateurs et peut-être pour
vous montrer qu' il ne fait pas de la
même façon que vous on ne sait jamais
avec lui il faut s'attendre à tout c'est
bien c'est une très jolie mentalité
quand on en arrive là vous savez alors
voilà n'est ce pas je vais vous avez des
trucs parce que je crois que là que déjà
fermé deux gérants je ne sais pas si non
elle ne développe pas mais les connais
les connaissent pas elle le garde pour
le prochain problème c'est celui de vous
il y aura dix mille et trois recettes de
cap et qu'elle a gardé un petit peu de
recul
alors voilà vous vous laissez lever à
bouillir n'est ce pas naturellement la
quantité de rennes n'a pas d'importance
il arrive pour nous de faire un demi
litre de crème
alors nous nous contenterons de prélever
sur le lait qui est en ébullition depuis
un moment cette ville la quantité alors
nous mettons dans la casserole cela ou
partie du truc du trucage si on peut
même s'estimer ainsi en rond dans une
casserole qui va servir à cuire a craint
on est directement dans cette saison le
sucre que l'on devrait normalement si
l'on se reporter à la plupart des
recettes de crème de mettre dans un bol
où on travaille le sucre avec les
journées en huit rond on met une partie
du lait de temps on reverse dans la
casserole et c'est là où justement le
bât blesse légèrement alors nous allons
prendre quatre heures ont pas il s'agit
d'une recette dans lequel il y as 355
enfants et 100 300 grandes lignes
présentant les 250 go
1809 paris iv et donc 4 il faut bien
reconnaître que les recettes de crème
anglaise tourne autour des mêmes
proportions à quelques dix grands après
alors souvent elles ont été traduites de
deux mesures d'étrangers à c'est à dire
dont soudaine sais quelle autre mesure
aux scandinaves et de ce fait elles sont
des 380 grammes ou des 410 grammes mais
je crois qu'on peut on peut se tenir à
des règles beaucoup plus urgent et
d'industrie de nos téléspectatrices
ce n'est pas l'esprit nous sert sbca
type de liaison et de mélanger ce sont
les noms à névez de suite
non mais sérieusement parce que certains
sont arrivés vers une chimie entre nous
deuxième risque de ne pas l'être
je ne veux pas savoir qui se seraient
non mais si nathan proposer des titres
ayant un petit papier elles ont noté 4
jaunes d'oeuf 150 g de sucre est pour le
moment à lui donner dont elles vont
devoir servir dans un instant c'est bien
ça salah le passé ça oui moi écouter
sinon c'est un petit peu je vais l'aimer
mais c'est moi qui suis gentil va encore
une fois dangereux qu'un clarac trois
noms de l'association c'est en tout cas
voilà s'aliénant les dépasser
car il est parti de roi et en mettre
cinq remorqueurs ajouté non non non non
non tu un peu de lait entre 110 et s'est
pas excusé managérat labaye jamais dire
ce qu'elle en pense la wii croyait
cavale sur ie la peinture tant
qu'intervenante en europe
alors voilà regarde alors ici j'ai mis
les quatre jaunes et le sucre et je vais
lui faire absorber
c'est très très important on voyait pas
je vais faire à absorber le sucre par
les gens progressivement et en faisant
ils seraient âgés de 15 à bourgoin dans
la famille
enfin bon alors j'ai jugé qu'en fait
absorber le sucre lentement et sans une
très grande importance parce que nous
appelons brûlé le fait de le faire trop
vite
et effectivement il se produit les
petits pois un rouge dans le mélange et
qui prouve que les eaux ont été cuits
par le sucre par la rapidité avec
laquelle ils ont été absents alors que
la voyez-vous maintenant le sucre est
entièrement absorbée par les jambes pour
aller parler et il s'agit de le
travailler
alors on dit on le fait blanchi alors
regarde je vais mettre l'accent le show
et c'est là le deuxième je m'excuse de
vous demande de m'excuser plus
exactement
alors là aussi bien sur une chaise alors
ici je le blanchit je travaille et je
t'en es au chaud c'est à dire que je
commence à donner à la casserole une
certaine chaleur qui va ce communiqué
naturellement au mélange qui va me
permettre de réussir cette partie dc6 de
la préparation c'est la question c'est
blanc à l'oreille aux sabres à chicago
ont blanchi
quant à laurent simplement la piste
touché avec la main je continue alors et
où les boues violemment il va passer par
eux continuent à mélanger et puis je
vais revenir ici lentement lentement
très lentement
non mais la vrai rival le mouvement
inverse tout à l'heure qui consistera
les 10,6 sur le court no sans estomac
alors ça c'est du café solubiliser et du
café soluble
alors vous savez qu en ce moment il y en
a dans le commerce et il ya du café
lyophilisé le lyophilisé aussi mieux
peut-être que le ch a fait simplement
une carrière j'ai mis moins d'une grosse
cuillère mais je vous dis à la couleur
si c'est suffisant parce que c'est ça
c'est du café non solubles et du café
tout est ouvert au café moulu alors oui
j'ai pas fait pour un autre il est
soluble le café alors toutes ces
précautions vous entendez sans superflu
laisse pas juste envers réalité par tout
doucement catherine vous en paix vous
auriez dû le dire n'oubliez pas que vous
êtes extrêmement tutin à cette émission
ok mais je ne me manque pas je peux
donner mais je ne peux pas je veux que
vous restiez là alors regardez regardez
seigneur extraordinaire et j'ai vraiment
on n'a pas la pression mis exactement
quatre ans qui devait m'envoyer un
impact à face
bien parce qu'il faut que ça soit
vraiment au café vous savez vous savez
que l'on met du café dans le chocolat ou
le familia galinou sa trompe toujours
les jambes quand même tout petit peu de
cas fait comme ça dans beaucoup de
chocolat on enrichit à ceux d'il ya
quelque chose en plus là alors ça y est
john's envers c'est ici le d'emprunt de
milito donné la salle
et voyez-vous dans un coup comme ça et
puis nous allons remuer mélanger
là non plus il n'y a pas de risque que
nous visions dans d'autres émissions
vous faites ça on souffre et a préconisé
ce serait difficile de donner un petit
coup de fouet ça va beaucoup plus vite
au départ c'est beaucoup plus sûr mais
on ne plie pas aux fous et on crie à la
règle non non vous mélangez alors
regardez voyez où il ya de la mousse sur
le la crème et moment où cette mousse se
résorbera la crème sera pratiquement
cuit alors là il faut faire assez
attention parce qu'effectivement alors
là il n'y a pas de reddition
si on arrive à l'ébullition la crème
tourner saviez rien faire est ce que
vous voyez emmené ses deux urgences et
le rouge l'an alors d'un jouet c'est en
voyant rouge et un voulez vous faire
voir que dans le fond il un à glace
voilà c'est ça alors ya de la glace et
le second met donc un espèce de raie
bien marie à l'envers est où là la
cuisson à envoyer et bien ça y est hissé
les biens alors elle n'a ce qu'on
appellera à une passe ont immédiatement
dans le froid et voyez vous c'était
juste le moment
alors là ça a été vraiment très rapide
et c'est pourquoi c'est à la fois
beaucoup plus simple si l'on a mais que
cette cuisson a été obtenue est très
difficile
sans arriver jusqu'à l'abolition c'est à
la fois très simple est aussi assez
compliqué en ce sens que quelques
secondes de trop sont très vite atteinte
au moment précis où plus 90 il sait rien
c'est une surveillance très vigilants
alors nous allons regarder quelles sont
les méthodes qui peuvent nous permettre
d'obtenir si nous le désirons non je
m'en vais l'utiliser à nouveau semaine
qui va l'envoyer au le geste évidemment
je vais mettre immédiatement du les deux
dans un autre demi litre et je
m'entraînais recelait ici à bouillir pas
ce que nous allons faire une deuxième
opération alors là cette opération je
suis en train de poursuivre s'appelle le
vannage on va à la crème on l'a revu
afin qu'elle ne fasse pas de gros mots
de groom l'eau qu'elle ne passe pas de
carton qu'elle soit très lisse n'est ce
pas en lapin à la fin de la préparation
mais là elle est terminée n'est ce pas
n'y a plus rien y faire elle va
s'épaissir
alors là je vous disais il ya deux
secondes au lieu de dépôt parce que les
relais a tendance à nous on perd et
j'aurais pu d'ailleurs et il était tout
content mais cela me convenait
parfaitement et aussi par exemple
j'avais était trop loin dans la cuisson
et que j'ai actuellement la d une gamme
qui tourne
j'ai deux méthodes d'abord je peux la
mettre dans une bouteille tu es avec
grâce à un entonnoir il nous apprend
qu'elle est au med l'est pas mais je
l'aï retourné si vous voulez
cette fois on la verra la bouteille on a
ce truc là
le col de la bouteille avec une spatule
en bois en bouche et on remue violemment
en général ça réussit quand la bouteille
et casse-pattes quand la bouteille
cassée vivement recommandée notre crème
est encore incertaine a commencé par
faire tout de suite
mais ceci étant dit il y a encore une
autre méthode qui est très très très
très pratique
un nom qui consiste à la fouetter avec
un mixeur alors grâce à un médecin n'est
pas vous mettez une belle mentalité
vous auriez pu vous dire que çà et là
bouquet on ne m'avait rien dit vous avez
vous avez jardin micro vont très bien
avec ça c'est l'état d'esprit
bon passons pas ça ne s'était pas tout à
fait assez profond bon eh bien
maintenant je vais vous montrer comment
on fait tout en prime ils ne paient pas
assez comme ça une somme assez qu'on n'a
pas forcément la caméra café n'est pas
seul et etc et les recettes qui les
fabriquent pas tout alors non nous
parlons sérieusement
brik atteint cette fois c'est pas bien
alors vous prenez une spatule fait le
ménage
alors voyez vous il ya un demi litre de
lait qui est en pleine ébullition
je prends de la poudre de café nous
avons couru café et là attention nous
continuons par catherine c'est bien
c'était bien au début j'en choisis bien
maintenant là et jamais depuis hier à
soupe de café de da moulu le dans
l'inhibition juste une évolution en est
à soi évidemment de bien ça fait 10
degrés ça fait du café au lait mais du
café au lait et qui est bien meilleur
que le café au lait qui est obtenu avec
un extrait de café quand c'est au
travers d'un filtre
je ne parle pas du café soluble
actuellement qui est une technique
absolument moderne et excellent
d'ailleurs mais je parle dédié et
technique vient ça c'est beaucoup moins
trash salon de l'e3
alors on laisse reposer un tout petit
peu on jette un peu d'eau froide de dans
l'année c'est léopard c'est nouveau
c'est la mode et les verrières vous
allez voir à partir de maintenant les
cuisiniers ont ça peut s'habiller en
léopard et deuxièmement on passe au
travers de swat
dans l'aisne ce qui est très bien soit
également d'un filtre ordinaire
c'est-à-dire d'un papier buvard
bon ça c'est une méthode vous savez que
le café au lait et parfaitement
indigeste ça pour la bonne raison le
saviez peut-être pas responsables le cas
j'aurais parfaitement indigeste parce
que parce que le lait est effectivement
un peu là le café en fait le relais de
ce cahier or le le lait ne se digère
bien que lorsqu'il écailler vous voyez
les recettes et yaourts et autres et
autres mais il y a un système pour ceux
qui sont fragiles qui ont qui ont un
petit peu de talent et régis ou le café
au lait c'est de faire du lait d'amande
et de mères âgées celles et d'amandes
avec du café
si à ce moment là on enlève complètement
le système de base est le cas le café au
lait d'amandes et parfaitement digeste
et cela est très fort et on se lance
alors il faut pas essayer de faire les
amandiers ça marche pas ça en a qui ont
essayé mais vous avez peur non eh bien
non catherine roux n'avait pas de risque
alors je vous disais que noront fabrique
évidemment exactement comme le coco on
met les amandes avec le petit appareil
vous étiez vous montez tout à l'heure là
qui m'a très bien qui éclabousse un peu
c'est vrai mais un récit dakar va pas
réciter inconvenable ça ne se passe pas
alors il suffit de mettre des amandes
fraîches et monde est là dedans avec un
peu d'eau ayant peu de sucre cuit de
l'ordre mais antico le mixeur web et on
essaiera peut-être oui vous ne l'avez
pas vous le cacher mais je m'excuse
alors si monsieur charles dauchy
décidément sur beaucoup de messieurs qui
gagne en ce moment a réagi de la cuisine
et je crois que c'est vrai que nos amis
quel spectateur indien
j'habite 16h einstein à lille et nous a
fait détruire comme un certain temps et
nous a fait des trucs farsi en papillote
non non je ne me manque pas du tout et
j'ai même le même reproche aux non
seulement ça mais il l'a trouvé très
sérieux non en termes de recettes de
café où j'ai aussi le casse-cou les
fresques bon est ce que vous n'avez pas
donné le prix un monsieur qui aurait
trouvé une recette de café qui serait
l'ami les deuxièmes versé s'allume alors
les rasades par exemple une supposition
non alors écoutez je suis sûr je me
souviens très bien de cette recette de
tweed qui est particulièrement
intéressant parce que elle apporte
quelque chose de nouveau et vous serez
les truites au fond le tri de torrents
merveilleux mais dans le commerce on ne
trouve pas il faut être pêcheur alors
celui qui utilise est détruite élevage
au moins 6h les faire le moins possible
si tu m'intéresses elle respire alors
est ce que ça veut dire oui alors je
voudrais aussi vous expliquer que l'on
peut il ya plusieurs façons de truquer
la crème et l'autre manière et un truc
qui jamais vraiment moi moi j'ai le truc
moi je ne trouve pas je n'ai aucun
intérêt voyez j'ai fait cette crème
dieu merci que je ne voulais les
disperser assez abondamment où il va
mais je n'ai pas eu besoin de quelqu'un
il est toujours fausse crise c'est sûr
par truie color vous allez voir vraiment
très bon
alors il ya un moyen très simple qui
consiste à ajouter de la récuse à la
première réparation sont difficiles
la règle de bande de terre et les fécule
d'ailleurs de maïs qui sont également
très bas et il en faut pas beaucoup
voyez vous voilà à peu près la quantité
qui est nécessaire pour arriver à lier
un demi litre de crème anglaise
car il ne s'agit pas de tomber la caméra
manga
pâtissière car la seule différence qu'il
peut y avoir entre la crème anglaise de
la crème pâtissière c'est que la seconde
est un gars est fabriqué avec de la
paris alors la farine est une chose la
fécule et hot shots
c'est tout à fait différent science et
et non ou non non catherine c'est trop
vite dit je savais où ils ont créé les
regarder comme ça se ressente 1 135
blanc et l'autre et ça c'est très blanc
est bien là tu es kull à l'intérêt
d'être utilisé très facilement
alors pour utiliser cette figure il
faudra je ne vais pas l'utiliser ce
maintenant je vais vous faire un
rassemblement
comment il faut qu'il entende - et ayew
avec une cuillère en train peu de la
crème qui a tourné
on la met dans l'accueillir s'étaient
antilles dans la cuillère simplement ça
suffit et avec le bout du doigt comme
ceux ci ont fait dissoudre la fécule là
il faut faire très attention parce que
le bout du doigt à son intérêt son
importance car il touche et il voit
exactement envahissant exactement ce qui
se passe et il va dissoudre très
exactement la paix créée par vince est
parfaitement délayé alors là il va la
remettre dans la sla dans la craie alors
là ce n'est pas utile de la ville
doivent être l affaire
alors pour la leur faire manger car il
s'agit de la face à gisèle est persuadé
qu'ils peuvent le mans les et qui va pas
être facile
est ce que vous avez dit ils vont être
un des dix ans du fonds cela dépend si
alors on va essayer avec des muscats la
cuillère préfère se dire que tout compte
fait ils peuvent
quant à des biscuits je crois que vous
faites alizés une génoise
alors je préconise le large de noix de
pin de gênes les les varoises
les humoristes les gars toril autorise
au riz de camargue de seulement les
autres étant exclus elle a aussi mené
ensuite toujours nombreux à se sentir
tous aux journées en a encore c'est très
joli ça si je donne un petit coup de
fouet de dans ce foyer mécanique vous
verriez nous allions tous la givrine et
au pardon
c'est parti pour les sports d'hiver se
transforme en huile peloton quant au
sort à lui les plantes d'ailleurs bien
alors à une cuillère on a plus beau là
alors la connaissez froid et quand vos
risques sont vraiment limités je crois
que c'est vous qui allez porter ce plat
sur la table de monsieur courte et est
ce que c'est parce que vous êtes là je
sais ce que c'est inscrit au jeu clichés
qui est courageux c'est la première fois
que je jouais une crème au café c'est au
ventilateur qui vous écouter vraiment
bien monsieur côté
personnellement ça qu'est ce que je vois
à l'égard de mes chats non je veux pas
pour rien
si vous changez un caillou sur ses
terres alors bien je crois que monsieur
contiennent exagère beaucoup jusqu'en
même d'accord sur beaucoup de chevaux
par litre avait quand vous parlez par
exemple des différences des quatre et je
pense que nous avons quelquefois des
objectifs différents
vous vous êtes un chef vous travaillez
en chef
moi je travaille pour des femmes ce qui
sont toujours des femmes très ses
collègues qui ont toujours un problème
de temps et puis des femmes qui ne
savent pas faire la cuisine très souvent
car il ne s'agit pas d'entrer rien donc
qui ne savent pas beaucoup faire la
cuisine
j'admirais la façon dont vous mesurez le
ministre de lèvres exactement c'est réel
c'est pas joli restés loyaux à l'appui
parce que ayons très soigneux et vendre
pour que j'étais un petit peu ce que dit
madame gérant c'est parce qu'elle ne
peut pas mesurer deux minutes maintenant
je ne reproche pas admirer la dextérité
quand même
non c'est mon coeur mais le temps
qu'avait humala au nom de monsieur côté
je crois que c'est ce qu'a fait de
différence du café justement ça tient au
fait que j'essaie toujours de concevoir
rédiger des recettes qui peuvent être
faites n'importe qui et de la façon la
plus simple possible qui demande moins
de temps possible j'irai pas toujours le
moins d'argent possible mais là ce n'est
pas le cas donc tout au moins que
n'importe laquelle puisse reproduire
facilement n'importe qui puisse repasser
à merci merci au nom de tout noter sa
fille je veux une fois mis en place mais
je suis d'accord avec vous mais je
voudrais souligner que la méthode que
j'ai employée est une méthode qui est
une simplification alors je parle de la
façon de will h plié le point très
délicat sénateurs opération et quand on
reçoit un courrier tout le monde a peur
de faire yeux hagards alors ils iront
bien en art
on n'attend pas qu'elles soient cuits ou
bien alors on attend trop longtemps et
quand on reçoit un courrier lectrices en
trouve notre les neuf lettres service
pour demander comment cuire la crème en
dentelle mais c'est très cher sa part
est étranger la raison qui a fait
choisir cette recette paca t elle m'a
dit moi même j'ai des difficultés pour
caler sur la coque et la crème anglaise
l'a dit a ajouté avec laquelle j'aborde
président mais alors là oui oui oui ah
oui ça reste comme ça mais les sorties
aussi compter avec monsieur l'hiver
peut-être
rare et noir il pourrait peut-être me
parler d'autres 712 les zones et bien
entendu mais nous dire quel a été son
propos précisément dans ses mille et une
recettes ce que vous avez abordé
d'autres patients with an cirq au fond
le café on peut l'employer dans toutes
les tous les domaines sucre et donc j'ai
commencé par les différentes façons de
faire du café
et puis les crèmes comme vous l'avez dit
la pâtisserie j'en ai pas mis énormément
parce que j'ai l'impression
malheureusement que les traditions de
pâtisseries tout en satisfaisant
importante et difficile se perdent et
que une femme qui lisse c'est ce livre
sotra ces pages 20 doute au moins
prendre à des choses très faciles ferme
on n'en est rien et sa voix le biscuit
de savoie avec une crème anglaise qui
ont pâti chez qui chante tellement bien
qui fait du biscuit de savoie ou que ce
bon monsieur continent n'avait pas dit
tout à l'heure que c'était un habit
cynique les chèvres bottées l'époque les
chefs de l'école dans la légende
également de la part de religieux dans
la légende maintenant le vieux bouc
heureusement vous dire el-assad et je
pense que ça vous remettra en mémoire
que notre émission n'a qu'une durée
limitée et que nous devons prendre congé
de nos téléspectateurs en leur
souhaitant bonne appétit et en espérant
qu'ils feront cette recette que vous a
suggéré aujourd'hui madame gérard et
qu'ils en font bien d'autres qu'ils
auront prises dans le livre mille et une
recettes avec le café vous préserverez
aussi du café dans des ide en des
recettes salut
allez on vous dit on va retomber à bien
la prochaine fois et merci à catherine
vient fimada vers 6 revers continuer à
l'appliquer
[Musique]